investigators in Mexico are trying to
determine the cause of an explosion on
board a ferry in Playa del Carmen on the
Caribbean coast surveillance cameras
captured the moment of the blast
yesterday as many as 25 people were hurt
on the dock including at least seven
Americans vladimir duthiers our
streaming network cbsn is here with the
details of the story from survivors who
are talking bad good morning good
morning Playa del Carmen is a popular
vacation destination a picturesque
resort town along the water one American
family of four was there on a beach
getaway when their trip took a
terrifying turn security camera footage
shows the moment a fireball ripped
through the center of the ferry the boat
had just docked at the beach town of
Playa del Carmen passengers were still
disembarking when the explosion sent
debris and shrapnel into the water and
the crowd emergency crews rushed to the
scene and tended to the injured Mexican
officials say 18 people were taken to
the hospital images of the aftermath
show a gaping hole in the center of the
ship Rebecca and Steve Long's family
were on the dock waiting for another
ferry to Cozumel when the blast happened
the couple's two young sons suffered
minor cuts and bruises from the
explosion they were taken to the
hospital where they receive stitches and
were released
thankfully no one was killed
local officials say preliminary reports
indicate the explosion was due to
mechanical failure a deeper
investigation into exactly what caused
that failure is ongoing looking at those
pictures it's hard to believe nobody was
killed it was edible explosion that's
amazing Thank You Vlad